benvenuti solita storia da oggi vivremo
una nuova storia è già nella serie di
oggi andremo a trovare la nonna cattiva
è tornata una sorta di grendi cattivo in
più c'è la versione speciale di
halloween
non sappiamo cosa succederà ma sappiamo
che la storia paurosa come piace a noi
ea voi voi mettetevi comodi preti pop
corn e lasciate un mi piace entro 5
secondi ecco ora
tempo scaduto prodi ricorda ciclo non so
perché io sono piccola
che carino tra l'altro odio lo stesso
cerchietto del mio personaggio così agli
orecchini coppa di gelato se sia muovi
qua non sapete che per ogni gameplay o
un paese ricchini diverso allora dove si
sa dove si va dalla nemmeno troppo
bisogna salire il mondo di questi taxi e
ne andiamo insieme andiamo in questo va
anche ai 61 il taxi ma vediamo che parlò
già ma il pilota luogo quindi in questo
gioco siamo tutti i bambini riferì che
siamo buonisti che scarica
dovrebbe già essere la nona cattivo
all'aja l'immagine della donna
l'inizio mai subito la storia io adoro
le storie di robles soprattutto per il
proseguo io sto bene se non avete visto
le altre abbiamo fatto il compleanno
della bambola cattiva e paci faglia sua
dose vederlo poi dopo di questa è così
qua perché invece di camminare striscia
oggi vuole un pò voi dove voleva
attraversare la porta dove sei e così
qua a casa del nonno la nonna sarebbe
questa nonna la nonna sta ancora
caricando ehi guardate cosa ho trovato
ha detto un giocatore vediamo che cosa è
carino il caso sono un lupo quindi
stiamo eccola non ora si è caricata
mettiamola bravo che arrabbiato sta
pestando i fornelli spezia markit e la
nonna appena finito di cucinarsi
qualcosa così nursey dei panini e dei
biscotti ci possiamo fidare a mangiare i
biscotti di treni cattiva
andiamo a mangiare allora meglio i
croccantini dal gatto forse
molto buoni la nonna dice grazie mi fa
piacere che vi sono piaciuti abbiamo
mangiato i biscotti adesso dice don
feels good non mi sento così bene non mi
sento molto bene con noi o leggere
qualcosa sono allergica alle noccioline
vedremo credevo che fossero al
cioccolato hai preso qualcosa per le
emergenze si nella mia borsa ok normale
presto troviamo la borsa quindi la borsa
dobbiamo trovare edizione forse sopra
non lo stop freghiamo sia altrimenti
morirono sopra non si può andare
dove questa borsa
[Musica]
ma questa con il lucchetto
grazie ritrovato la borsa non ha dice
beh prima che iniziamo la festa vadano
negozio prendere qualcosa c'è qualcosa
di sospetto dobbiamo pulire entro 50
secondi presto ciò che ritornerebbe
proprio si può venire adesso l'ho già
pulito tutto e che cosa devo disk area
ecco qua
qua no ho solo questo il top o meno a
che cosa deve volere lieto perché rimane
seduto qua abbiamo pulito tutto dice
sarà molto felice quando tornerò se
dobbiamo guardare un po di simmetria
siamo ok bravo un po di tv eccoci qua
siamo seduti a guardare la tv
era la pubblicità di un altro gioco
roberta in terrestre tardi forse
dovremmo andare a letto ma la mamma non
è ancora tornata a noi giugno colletto
di un po strano è che migliaia che
andiamo a dormire vabbè vogliono tutti
andare a dormire andiamo e così qualche
anno di sopra però possiamo giocare
chiese wow casini però giochi quando
iniziano le cose paurose per ora è tutto
tranquillissimo non va a suonare qui lo
xilofono
[Musica]
di testa sulla dello spin off ora
vediamo se riesco a tirare la palla
interna o ci ha già provato io no così
hanno detto non vota in tempo a leggere
ma lui non è mai tornata infatti non
sono sicure stavamo giocando talmente
tanto che non ho sentito nessun rumore
molto bene non ti preoccupare inizia
bene al sveglia ok buonanotte ragazzi ei
106 messo a dormire junior canestro
vabbè vado a dormire nei tornei sdraiati
brevi scaglia temendo forse inizieranno
alle cose poco ma avete sentito c'è un
temporale fuori
io sto dormendo che sta succedendo è
tutto ok c'è stato un rumore fortissimo
e che veniva da sotto penso di sotto ma
che abbiamo bisogno di aiuto ok andiamo
io dobbiamo segnare piano di sotto di
notte al buio con la tempesta ok
dobbiamo inseguire il jerry
berlino vuole vedere la nonna
eccola dobbiamo nascondere sa io stavo
guardando minimi lo storico uno stadio
proprio ho scritto che che non bisogna
svegliare i sonnambuli lemon a bola non
vi preoccupate l'aiuto di tornare a
letto che grazie ha preso qualcuno o no
forse è meglio scappare adesso no
aspetta lì è ferma lì vicino alla tv
peggio non farti presi ma no salendo su
prova risalire subito
quindi lei anche lei può salire sui muri
e sui muretti sui muri io sono questo un
lavandino ok meno male lei sta cercando
di salire le scale che fa io mi nascondo
assieme agli altri qua
successo
arrivando eccola aiuto stato
terrificante forte non ho mai visto lei
fare questo prima parte è tornata nella
sostanza speriamo pero io sto salendo su
a binasco ditino e la camera presto no
aspetta dice di seguire jerry
guerri entrato nella giocare qui
che cosa facciamo se lo fa ancora
dobbiamo forte bloccarle la porta di
casa che continui a farlo conosco mia
nonna di legno che per bloccare le porte
o che dobbiamo trovarle presto dobbiamo
bloccarla prima che si spegne nuovamente
faccia nuovamente la sonnambula poi per
cosa poi non è da verso un aula e tutto
pià troviamo le chiavi per aprire al
passato ok sono entrata eccole le ho
trovate erano qua nella lavanderia
ok vado a mettere le travi di legno
quelle che ho trovato presto prima che
si svegli
ok come chiave per china fashion il led
devo dire che anche gli altri giocatori
sono molto bravi stiamo facendo un
ottimo lavoro di squadra
io non sono le travi e
ragazzi
spaventarvi beh tua nonna che fa trovare
una via d'uscita ma che riusciamo
semplicemente dalla porta principale
non ci ho pensato questo è bene come non
possiamo farlo dice gerry perché mia
nonna controlla la casa ha messo la
mente d'allarme dappertutto e non sei il
codice per spegnerlo non lo disse a
nessuno il codice ma è già volato far
dentro quindi cosa facciamo quella
scatola nera è così scatola quella che
si erano l'entrata è vero quella che
cos'è che troviamo le chiavi possiamo
aprirla a vedere che cosa c'è dentro
nero forse c'è un'altra chiave da
qualche parte nel grande indagati forse
c'è un'altra uscita magari non ne paga
marolla poco funzionale di 6 0 che
dobbiamo trovare la chiave dove potrebbe
essere vediamo una scorta da qualche
parte
che cos'era quel rumore che cos'era hoc
è risvegliata penso che la nonna se si è
svegliata con la camera cosa facciamo
adesso
o no cosa
sarà molto arrabbiata e meglio se
rimaniamo qui al sicuro e dissi se apro
la porta me ne pentirò
aprire la porta oggi e per dare a tutti
noi di qualcosa in tema non certo lui ha
già aperto la porta
non vi preoccupate
nascondetevi casomai succeda qualcosa
aprendo la forza che lo produce ha detto
non lo so perché è stato dietro le trovi
che abbiamo messo
la mamma è arrabbiata
preso jerry sì o no cosa è successo a
proteggerli non lo so ma forse dovremmo
andare aprire la forza di nuovo
se non si prende dobbiamo vedere se
jerry sta bene e se fosse una trappola
invece
andiamo ragazzi non secondo me è una
trappola io non mi fido dove si no c'è
scritto che dobbiamo attrarre
diventerà un po strana questa stanza
sono delle catene cosa possiamo fare si
è scritto che ruota
deve esserci una porta segreta forse
professionalità poi c'è un'altra porta
fosse qualche chiave nascosta allora qui
c'è un'altra porta c'è una chiave bravo
trovato lo yoga te la chiave che adesso
forse la chiave per la scatola nera
si pesca questa ok vediamo arrivo cosa
siete dentro un'altra che lo sapevo una
chiave forse la notte per la cantina
cantina valera questa qui a fianco mi
chiamo
apri
[Musica]
spaventoso usciamo da qui presto ok
vediamo come la cantina gerry
eccolo ora in prigione
stai bene sì sto bene tutto quello che è
successo è successo così velocemente al
mese non contento che stai bene ma sei
mesi stretto passato prima no la nonna
di solito lascia questa porta chiusa
abbiamo trovato la chiave della scatola
nera nella stanza della la nonna è
ancora in giro non stiamo spero di no
non abbiamo abbiamo chiesto guarda c'è
un altro lucchetto descritto proviamo ad
incappare prima che si trovi dovevo
provare un'altra chiave
non lo so se una buona idea come non
sente la buona idea ma io mi ha detto
che allora qui c'è una scala che porta
su no questa è quella dove siamo scelti
r il dice che non dovremmo provare a
scappare perché lei è troppo arrabbiata
non so perché ma qualcosa mi dice r
contro qualcosa che sia della nonna
secondo me dobbiamo fidarci cercandolo
chiappe ma qui mi trovo niente devi
decidere sestese rimane qua o se vai via
io dico rimanere ok rimaniamo
vediamo si deciderà in base ai voti ok
rimaniamo e quindi tribuna votato
rimaniamo aveva quindi adesso dobbiamo
cercare la chiave forse ieri di se vi
prometto che niente succederà se non ci
pieghiamo di testa solissimo tornare
sopra ok andiamo mi dice ho un brutto
presentimento anch'io adesso scelta
delle frontiere infido tutto dio sono
delle radici occhi che si muove a chi ci
sta spiando angelo chiave patto alla
nonna che brutta grazie ger lo sapevo di
poter contare su di te no
tempo del rituale che rituale che cosa
sta succedendo o no dovevamo cliccare il
link del ricco evento
possiamo scappare adesso signora
manutentive perché ho fatto un
incantesimo su di lui lo posso
controllare quello che dice per questo
era così facile non potete scappare così
facilmente
forse devo monder vita cosa facciamo ora
dai ci sarà un modo per sconfiggerla
forse possiamo provare a scappare in una
maniera differente
buona fortuna tutto è bloccato a l'unico
modo per scappare dalla porta principale
che un codice segreto che solo io so no
non provare questo codice segreto e se
lui ti sfidiamo per poter avere il
codice le ha detto sì forse si può fare
posso fare un gioco divertente con
ok jerry speed di questa sera a questo
gioco divertente o no come avete potuto
capire la nonna un'ossessione per le
chiavi quindi dovete trovare le cinque
chiavi e metterle qui è una carta con il
codice apparirà da qualche parte ok
sbrighiamoci dopo che hai trovato la
carta con il codice mette il codice nel
sistema di allarme e sarete liberi
quindi questa è l'ultima prova ok allora
qualora 1 a 3 oggi lavoro cena chiave
viola freddo e infatti c'è uno nuovo più
good luck dice buona fortuna dice la
nonna mi prendere questa chiave che
forse adesso si può prendere fino a 1
che ho preso anche io le ho preso una
quindi la dobbiamo mette tra qui e mi
stupisco del tempo anni manca solo una
sono quattro dai dove sarà l'altra
racchiuso
eccola
bel gioco di squadra adesso dobbiamo
tornare con un pezzo di carta con il
codice trova il pezzo di carta nascosto
questi occhi ecco un brodo prova vetro e
ora dobbiamo mettere il codice qui
possiamo scappare si trova qui qui qui
siete riusciti a fare la task adesso
potete uscire non ci credo che ci lascia
uscire così buona fortuna là fuori
non sono sicuro di questo dice metti il
codice così possiamo andare via da qui
viva misteriche questo codice ey come ok
ok non è scappato lasciando più fatta e
che bisogna camminare
l'impressione che non ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok ma
dove siamo
questo è il giardino della no non ne ho
idea il giardino della nonna
la porta si è chiusa siamo rimasti
chiusi fuori in giardino
cosa facciamo ora dobbiamo trovare una
via d'uscita
non ho idea ma
adesso la magia
non lo so ma dove siamo finiti
e vince premio bloodrayne big bang a
mappe musica finale brutto o non ci
credo come in pace abbiamo avuto il beta
ending quindi vuol dire che le nostre
scelte hanno portato a questa fine in
cui siamo finiti male perché si sono
abbattuti nel giardino il terremoto se
voi avete fatto queste esclusive tesi
commenti che per voi quale bad quale
finale avete avuto scrivete solo nei
commenti e ora vi lasciamo a quattro
mesi
cliccate altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
buona visione ciao